say hello to the first hot hatch from
Kia with a snoot CGT the Korean car
maker wants to take on the pocket
rockets from Volkswagen and Opel our car
tester Carla Simmons wants to see
whether it's got what it takes let's
start on the outside the seed treads in
line between boy racer aggression and
range-topping style with its aggressive
but sweeping lines the little hot hatch
certainly looks the part with its angry
face but flashes of chrome give it a
more upmarket feel the design is the
work of former Volkswagen designer Peter
Schreyer the Kia looks just as good from
behind as it does from the front the
twin rear light clusters dominate the
rear and the twin exhausts if there's
something special under the hood and
there is a 1.6 liter turbocharged petrol
engine time now to hit the road
Corolla we'll be putting the Kia through
its paces on an old race circuit there's
no better place to unleash all of the
GTS 150 kilowatts of power
she says the seeds is a real hoot to
drive there's a lot of power to tap but
she feels the car doesn't really hook up
well coming out of the turns it's like
there's a delay in getting the power to
the front wheels does d5500 k-fed
sugatas medicines bad but the CGT makes
up for that with its sweet handling that
makes it a real blast to drive in the
twisties the sporting flair on the
outside continues on the inside red
stitching and lettering remind you that
this is no run-of-the-mill car there's
no shortage of buttons and shiny inlays
in here the wraparound seats are crafted
from suede and make you feel like you're
in a race car the Kia doesn't skimp on
spec and is fitted with a handy
rear-view camera to aid parking despite
being in the compact class the seeds
trunk offers a truly cavernous 380
litres of storage space it also has a
false floor in which to store valuables
Cola is a big fan of the inlays on the
steering wheel she thinks it looked the
real deal the only problem she says is
that they can be a bit of a headache at
night they reflect the light from all of
the buttons and gizmos here in the cabin
and that can be a bit of a distraction
when you're trying to drive by they
stand out is a blink lista in this large
beagle or daemon special a plane
converter
the last thing you want is to be
distracted because this hot hatch really
packs a punch it accelerates from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in just seven
point seven seconds
despite that performance it's not going
to break the bank kia says the car can
cover 100 kilometers with a relatively
low 7.4 liters of gas our test car was a
bit more thirsty and consumed 10 litres
but that's still in line with the
competition time for the final word on
the Kia Corolla thinks it's a genuine
alternative to the other hot hatches out
there but she would like to see a bit
more attention to detail in the interior
all in all though she says the Kia has
got it right with a new CGT another
thing that appeals to her is the price
one person attorney outfitting Kia's
place to step pies the top spec GT track
version that we tested is available in
Germany for around twenty seven thousand
euros